-On dit souvent
qu'en politique,
il faut savoir faire
et faire savoir.
"Agir et communiquer",
c'est le leitmotiv de mon invité,
qui compte incarner la relève
de la droite à l'Assemblée.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Antoine Vermorel.
-Bonjour.
-A l'adolescence,
à 14 ans,
quand la plupart des ados
tentent de faire pression
sur leurs parents pour sortir
le samedi soir, vous,
vous avez supplié votre père
pour aller à un meeting
de Nicolas Sarkozy
à Clermont-Ferrand.
C'est ça ?
-Exactement.
C'était le premier meeting
de ma vie.
C'était un meeting
sur la ruralité.
On était en 2007,
c'était la pleine folie sarkozyste.
On croyait en l'homme.
Mon père n'était jamais allé
à un meeting électoral...
-Vous l'y avez emmené ?
-Je ne pouvais pas conduire,
donc il fallait qu'il m'emmène.
-Vous avez aussi fait
votre stage de 3e chez le député
de votre circonscription.
-Avec Yves Nicolin, une semaine.
Il a été député
de ma circonscription
de 1993 à 2017.
-On dirait que vous saviez
que vous feriez
de la politique.
-J'avais ça en moi,
mais je sais pas d'où ça vient.
Dans ma famille,
on n'a jamais fait pas de politique,
on n'a jamais été encarté ou élu,
et pour autant,
mon premier souvenir politique
reste 2002.
J'avais 9 ans et...
-Le 21 avril 2002,
Jean-Marie Le Pen
au second tour de la présidentielle.
Comme vous ne pouviez pas
vous présenter avant vos 18 ans,
vous êtes allé
vers l'engagement associatif.
Vous avez fondé
et présidé
plein d'associations,
notamment un réseau social
d'entraide territorial,
L'annuaire roannais.
Vous avez mis en place
un réseau d'aide aux devoirs
pour des demandeurs d'asile à Dijon,
et assigné
Bouygues Télécom
pour publicité mensongère
sur son taux de couverture 4G
dans votre département,
afin que la couverture
du réseau mobile
soit améliorée.
Qu'est-ce qui a lancé
cette frénésie d'action
aussi jeune ?
C'était quoi, votre moteur ?
-Je suis fils d'éleveur laitier,
j'ai toujours habité à la campagne,
j'ai aussi vu
les injustices territoriales
qui sont aujourd'hui flagrantes
dans le pays.
J'ai voulu,
à mon échelle, m'engager.
J'ai été
délégué de classe.
Des engagements modestes, humbles,
des professeurs
qui m'ont montré cette voie
de l'engagement associatif,
qui font que j'ai pensé :
"On peut essayer
de changer les choses
"à notre échelle,
par les associations."
C'est pour ça
que je me suis engagé dans certaines
avant d'en créer
qui sont encore d'actualité.
-Votre principal "fait d'armes"
dans ce domaine,
c'est la création
d'un collectif,
Touche pas à ma bourse,
je la mérite,
contre la suppression
de la bourse au mérite
en 2014.
Ca vous a valu de faire
votre première télévision.
*-Antoine Vermorel
a désormais
un peu de mal
à joindre les deux bouts.
*-Je suis fils d'éleveur laitier,
d'un milieu modeste.
J'ai eu mon baccalauréat
avec 18,3 de moyenne
et j'avais une bourse
de 1800 euros par an,
200 euros par mois
pendant l'année universitaire.
*-Depuis cet été,
la mobilisation a grossi :
courriers aux députés français,
pétition sur Internet intitulée
"Touche pas à ma bourse,
je la mérite".
Enfin, sur le plan européen,
Antoine et ses amis
souhaitent créer
une bourse européenne
et doper ainsi
la mobilité.
-Cette guerre
contre la ministre de l'Education
de l'époque,
elle a été gagnée.
Vous avez obtenu l'annulation
de la circulaire
en allant devant le Conseil d'Etat.
Cette victoire a changé des choses,
dans votre vie ?
-Ca a été fondateur
de mon engagement politique,
car je suis passé
de l'associatif au politique.
Là, je me rends compte
que l'engagement
peut avoir de vrais résultats,
car si avec mes collègues,
on n'avait pas attaqué
cette décision au Conseil d'Etat,
la bourse aurait disparu.
Elle a été rétablie
grâce à cette décision.
Ca m'a permis
d'assumer pleinement
qui j'étais,
d'où je venais,
pourquoi j'étais engagé
en politique.
Ce que certains avaient pu
me faire voir,
notamment à Sciences Po,
comme une sorte
de difficulté sociale,
le fait de venir
d'un milieu
où l'on fait
très peu d'études supérieures,
ça m'a permis de dire
que j'étais fier d'où je venais.
Je reste très fier
de mes racines agricoles,
malgré ce mépris social
qu'on peut avoir parfois.
J'ai fait de cela une force.
-Vous n'avez jamais envisagé
de reprendre la ferme
de votre père, je crois.
-Non.
Pour autant, j'aidais.
J'ai toujours
ce souvenir-là...
A la maison,
c'était les devoirs d'abord,
et une fois terminés,
mon père m'emmenait à l'extérieur
et je l'aidais à la ferme.
C'est un métier très dur.
La traite, c'est matin et soir.
Les repas de famille,
le dimanche midi,
on en rentrait plus tôt,
car mon père avait la traite.
Et puis, il y a eu
cette crise de 2009,
la crise laitière.
Malgré le travail fourni,
vous n'avez pas
de revenus suffisants
pour nourrir votre famille.
Ces raisons ont fait que...
Je suis content
que mon père
ait trouvé un successeur.
C'est une vraie
richesse familiale.
-Ce milieu social
où vous avez grandi,
ça nourrit
votre engagement politique,
aujourd'hui ?
-Oui, parce que j'ai aussi vécu
cette forme de déconnexion
de certains élus,
le reproche
que mes parents
peuvent faire à des élus,
et je fais attention
de ne pas leur ressembler,
mais c'est toujours un risque,
quand on est à Paris,
d'oublier d'où l'on vient.
La dernière promesse
de campagne
qu'on avait avec ma suppléante,
c'était :
"Quoi qu'il arrive dimanche,
on se souviendra d'où l'on vient."
Je pense que c'est
une belle promesse qu'on peut faire
à tous ceux
qui nous font confiance.
-Cette lutte pour le maintien
de la bourse au mérite
vous a fait rencontrer
des responsables politiques
de la droite,
comme Eric Ciotti,
Laurent Wauquiez,
Michel Barnier,
dont vous êtes resté
assez proche, politiquement.
Ca vous a aidé
à vous lancer en politique ?
-Oui, cette rencontre
avec Michel Barnier,
qui est resté aujourd'hui
un ami,
que j'ai accueilli chez moi
pendant le congrès LR...
Encore aujourd'hui, on déjeune
et on se voit régulièrement.
Son expérience
est une source d'enrichissement
très importante.
Ca a été l'occasion
de rencontrer aussi les élus,
la droite que je suivais
depuis longtemps,
évidemment,
mais à un moment
où on se dit :
"Tiens, pourquoi pas moi ?"
-En 2017, vous devenez
collaborateur parlementaire
de deux députés LR,
Robin Reda et Damien Abad.
Damien Abad,
qui est devenu,
quelque temps plus tard,
président du groupe à l'Assemblée.
Vous prenez du galon
en devenant
collaborateur de groupe.
Ces années ont dû
vous permettre d'apprendre
sur le fonctionnement
du Parlement.
Au-delà de ça,
quelles leçons
vous en avez tirées
sur le mandat de député ?
-Cette nécessité
qui est à la fois,
pour les députés de l'opposition,
de faire des propositions,
de faire vivre
le débat public,
et aussi cette importance
d'être enraciné localement.
Damien et Robin
sont deux députés
qui ont fait
d'autres choix que moi...
-Qui sont maintenant
dans la majorité présidentielle.
-...qui restent très proches
de leur circonscription,
et j'ai appris ça de leur part,
en plus
de mon engagement personnel.
-Vous avez dû patienter
avant de vous lancer,
mais ensuite,
c'est allé très vite.
Vous avez été élu adjoint au maire
de Renaison en 2020,
puis vice-président
de l'agglomération de Roanne.
Conseiller départemental, également.
Ca donne l'impression
qu'il y a un petit côté
homme pressé, chez vous.
-C'est ce que mes opposants disent,
mais les habitants voient
mon dynamisme,
ma volonté de faire bouger
les choses.
-Pressé d'agir,
mais pressé quand même.
Il y a une impatience.
-Oui, j'ai envie
de faire,
j'ai envie
de faire bouger les lignes,
qu'une autre génération arrive.
Je me félicite.
Au département,
il y a des élus de l'opposition
jeunes comme moi, avec la volonté
de faire bouger les lignes,
peut-être différemment,
mais il y a une volonté
d'y aller
et c'est plutôt
une bonne chose,
vu le taux d'abstention,
le désintérêt de la jeunesse
sur de la politique.
-Pendant les législatives,
vous vouliez absolument vous rendre
dans chacune des 91 communes
de votre circonscription.
Vous l'avez fait savoir en posant
devant les panneaux à chaque fois.
On sent que la communication
en politique,
qui n'est pas toujours très bien vu,
vous, vous l'assumez.
-Oui, je considère que c'est
un gage de transparence, aussi.
C'est ce qu'on me dit :
"On sait ce que vous faites."
Après, on n'est pas
toujours d'accord
avec moi ou mes votes,
mais je ne cache pas
ce que je fais, ce que je porte.
Je pense
que c'est important.
Vous savez, Victor Hugo disait :
"La communication,
"c'est le fond
qui remonte à la surface."
Et donc, l'enjeu,
c'est pas de communiquer
pour communiquer,
mais d'abord de faire,
puis faire savoir.
C'est mon objectif
dans mes mandats.
-On a pas mal parlé de vous
au début de votre mandat,
car vous teniez vos permanences
dans un camping-car,
pour aller à la rencontre
de vos concitoyens.
Là aussi, ça peut faire
un peu gadget, peut-être ?
Communication à bon prix ?
-C'est pas gadget.
J'ai pas de permanence physique.
C'est un choix personnel.
Mon bureau fait
3 mètres par 3.
Mes collègues ont des bureaux
plus grands, c'est un autre choix.
Ma circonscription,
du nord au sud, d'est en ouest,
elle fait 1h30.
Je sais d'avance
que dans mon mandat,
je ne pourrais pas voir
tout le monde.
Je ne suis pas le seul
à faire ce choix,
d'autres députés
le font.
Je rencontre même
des chefs d'entreprise
qui ont vu la permanence mobile,
qui viennent
non pas pour me demander des choses,
mais m'en proposer.
-Donc, ça vous permet...
-De rencontrer et d'affirmer
cet enjeu de la proximité.
-Vous êtes pressé d'agir,
d'avoir des résultats.
A l'Assemblée, vous avez déposé
12 propositions de loi en 10 mois,
ce qui est plus
que ce que la plupart
des députés présentent en 5 ans,
mais combien ont été
mises à l'ordre du jour
de l'Assemblée ?
-Il faut se battre
pour qu'elles soient intégrées
dans les textes...
-Mais elles n'ont pas
été étudiées,
donc, ça sert à quoi ?
-La première chose,
c'est que c'est
un acte politique fort.
J'en ai fait une
sur la suppression
des allocations
aux parents maltraitants,
qui m'a fait rencontrer
Charlotte Caubel
et qui m'a dit qu'ils y penseraient
pour le projet de loi
de finances
de la Sécurité sociale.
Il y a des propositions...
-C'est de la communication
au service de l'action.
-J'en ai déposé une
sur la nationale 7 à Mably,
un sujet local qui m'intéresse,
et qui est un moyen de pression
vis-à-vis du gouvernement.
Pour moi,
la proposition de loi,
et on le voit,
dans les niches,
c'est un outil politique
au service d'une cause.
Je l'envisage comme ça,
et c'est pour ça
que j'utilise cet outil,
comme tous ceux
à ma disposition.
-Un dernier point m'a intéressé :
vous ne voulez pas laisser
le monopole de l'écologie
à la gauche.
Vous êtes en charge
de l'écologie
dans le contre-gouvernement
mis en place par Eric Ciotti
chez LR.
Vous pensez
que c'est un enjeu
que la droite
a longtemps négligé ?
-Oui, et on n'arrête pas
de dire
que nous sommes
"un parti de gouvernement".
Gouverner, c'est prévoir.
Si on ne prévoit pas
la crise climatique,
sera-t-on encore
un parti de gouvernement en 2027 ?
Il faut que la droite
puisse porter une voix différente
de celle de la gauche radicale
sur la question de l'écologie,
pour défendre aussi
l'industrie décarbonée,
le made in France,
et notre mode de vie
qui est en train de changer.
Il faut s'adapter
aux changements,
répondre à la question
des sécheresses, du manque d'eau,
de l'acidification des océans...
On a déjà porté des choses.
Georges Pompidou a créé
le premier
ministère de l'Environnement,
Nicolas Sarkozy
a lancé le Grenelle...
C'est à nous de mettre
ces forces historiques
et de nouvelles propositions
pour incarner
quelque chose en 2027
sur le sujet.
-On passe à notre quiz,
si vous le voulez bien.
Je vais commencer une phrase
et vous allez devoir la compléter.
"Les réseaux sociaux et moi."
-Favorable pour le contact
avec les habitants.
Pour Twitter,
un peu plus sceptique.
-"Quand les gens me parlent
"de mon âge..."
Ca vous énerve ?
-Ca m'énerve, ça m'agace,
autant que ça m'agacera
quand j'aurai 70 ou 80 ans.
J'ai pas forcément à m'occuper
que de la jeunesse,
comme une femme n'a pas
à s'occuper
que de l'égalité des sexes.
Quand vous êtes jeune,
vous devez porter tous les sujets,
pas ceux seulement liés
à votre âge.
-"Si j'arrête la politique,
"je me lance dans..."
-La création d'une ONG.
J'y ai déjà pensé,
c'était déjà dans mes plans.
C'est mon engagement associatif
d'avant
qui reviendra
le jour où j'arrêterai.
-Merci d'être venu
dans notre émission.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA